hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapter 22 book 2
and epic uses discourses contains a
really fascinating discussion friendship
or philia and friendship doesn't just
mean being friends of the person it can
also extend to the kind of good feeling
that we have towards those who are
saying on relatives you know they can
come as quite a lot and Epictetus says
something that seems quite paradoxical
which is that only the wise person can
really be a friend now he's got some
reasons why he is saying this I should
point out too that it's the word that's
used for why's there is prone Emil's not
these so close not the sage but the
person who has practical wisdom which
you know would include the sage but who
has prones who can think things through
so perhaps it's not saying that you have
to be an absolute stoic sage you know
totally developed but but perhaps you
have to have a certain you know it's a
process or the threshold of practical
wisdom now why is it that only the wise
person can love or if
French the word feel aim could mean
either to log or to show friendship it's
it's not as if you know sometimes people
want to say well there's all these
different kinds of love there's a gap
hey there's euros
there's philia Epictetus doesn't make
that sort of distinction well many of
the Greek authors actually don't so you
should see this as a sort of a wide
range of love why is it that only the
wise person can really do this well for
epictetus it has to do with the fact
that only the widest person really
understands what they're getting into
yeah only the wise person is able to
have the proper orientation he says
whatever the man is interested in he
naturally loves okay that makes sense
when men do men take an interest in
things evil not at all well do they take
an interest in things which are no
respect concerned look no none of these
either it remains therefore that men
take an interest in good things only and
if they take an interest in them then
they love them so this is this is not
meant to be a knock-down drag-out
argument but it's supposed to illuminate
what's going on we love the things that
we get to know we take an interest in
them because we think that they're good
right so when we think something is good
we invest some of our attention some of
our care some of our activity we get to
know a person we start to like them and
after a while we feel like we're friends
we begin to care for them so he says
whoever then has knowledge of good
things we know how to love them too but
when a man is unable to distinguish
things good from things evil and what is
neither good nor evil for both the
others how could he take the next step
and have the
or to love accordingly the power is
allowable arms to the wise man and to
him alone
so whatever exceed is the saying is the
widest person can distinguish good and
bad right so they know what to love and
they know how to love the other people
are going to be rather mixed up about
that they may think that they love and
they may appear to be loving but they're
not really going to be so other people
are mixed up about the good and the bad
and they're mixed up in in a variety of
ways it's not just one simple way first
off they're not really sure which things
are genuinely good and which things are
genuinely yet so let's take some
examples you know you get involved as a
kid with a lot of schoolmates probably
you're in contact with a lot of them now
if you're my age through Facebook right
or through you know Google+ or something
else perhaps if you have a professional
type through LinkedIn your alumni
networks right and you know if you feel
a certain commonality with them because
we've gone through certain experiences
together there may be some people you
didn't really like at the time but now
you know things have progressed and
gotten different they've changed you've
changed and you feel a friendly attitude
towards them you take an interest in
their life Epictetus thinks that that's
only going to go so far because insofar
as you're evaluating something other
than say their character who they really
are
you're not really friends with them you
know for example if you like somebody
you know not because of their great
capacities and skills that you think are
really wonderful but because they tend
to open doors for you they invite you to
the right parties they connect you up
with people that's more of an
instrumental relationship that's not
really a friendship you may feel nice
Viktoria to them you may feel a sense of
affection but is that something that's
really reliable
look all these external things that
often are you know what relationships
consist in those are not a satisfactory
basis for for a lasting relationship a
lasting relationship in terms of
affection similarly if you're told well
you have to love people because they're
your family well there's something to
that but that by itself is not going to
be enough to allow you to maintain that
sense of affection towards them quite
often people are involved with other
people and want to have a continuing
relationship and so behave in certain
ways towards them and / because they're
afraid of what might happen should they
allow the relationship to dissolve you
know security not being alone being
feeling like you're alive all these are
the sorts of things that people talk
about and epictetus would say these are
not reliable bases in part because these
people are mixed up about what's good
and what's bad they think that external
things are good and they you know pursue
their relationship on that basis there's
another way in which people are mixed up
- not only do they think that external
things are you know where the good and
the bad lie they don't remain constant
about that he's got some great
discussions of this in this section he
says here we go
you're frequently but wildered and and
disturbed by your external impressions
and overcome by their persuasive
character at one moment you consider
these things good and then
consider them though the same evil and
later on is neither good or evil and in
a word you're subject to pain the
theater and the turmoil and change in
the loving are you not changeable a
little bit later he says you don't
consider the same person's at one moment
good and at another moment bad do you
not at one woman to feel friendly
towards them and another unfriendly and
that one woman praise them well in
another moment you criticize them and
you know if we think about our own
experience this is something that we
frequently go through we are not as
constant as we would like to think that
we are this is what is possible to have
you know say a frenemy somebody that
you're really a rival with but you
pretend to be a friend with you know
these are all examples of being mixed up
about what's good and what's bad and
this is the condition of most people
according epictetus so something like
temporary friendship is indeed possible
but here's the key thing it's temporary
right the the sage the wise person or
even the Froemming loss the person who
has got it together they're not going to
be involved in these just temporary
friendships because they're looking for
something more lasting but other people
will be now however they last will they
last so long as nothing else comes
between them so here's the two key
questions we want to ask why does
something else come between them and why
does that affect the person's affections
well let's look at the examples that
epictetus give us which I think still
apply quite often in our own time he
says do you never see dogs fawning on
one another and playing with one another
so that you say nothing could be more
friendly but see what their friendship
amounts to throw a piece of meat between
them annuals to you
to find out throw likewise between
yourself and your son a small piece of
land and you will find out how much your
son wants to bury you the sooner the
better
and how earnestly you pray for your
son's death this is some pretty grim
stuff but empathy this is being very
realistic here about the prospects for a
lasting relationship of affection if we
are going to allow things to easily come
between us
he says throw them between you a pretty
wench
and the old man as well as the young man
falls in love with her or again a bit of
glory and if you have to risk your life
you'll see what the father but made us
did now Julius seeing daylight does
suppose that father joy is not to do you
imagine that he did not love his own
child when it was small and he was not
in agony when it had the fever and it
did not say over and over again if only
I had the fever instead and then when
the test comes upon him just see what
words he utters so you know we can go on
he says it's a general rule be not to
see that every living being is to
nothing so devoted as to its own
interest this is part of our nature but
it's not the whole of our nature and to
behave in that way is not actually to
have our Faculty of choice in accordance
with nature Epictetus wants to keep
reminding us so he says you know for
most people whatever it appears to stand
in the way of this interest being a
brother or father or child or loved one
or lover the being hates accuses and
curses it he has an example here even of
the gods he says if a man buried on when
we think that the gods stand in the way
of our attainment of what we want we
revile even that
they're statues to the ground and burden
their temples as Alexander ordered the
temples of escape lists to be burned
when his loved one died if a man goats
together in one scale his interest that
righteousness and what is honorable and
country and parents and friends they're
all safe but if he puts his interest on
one side of the scale and all these
other things on the other the interest
will pull it down and these other things
will go out the window so this is a big
problem if we allow ourselves to be
blinded essentially by our self-interest
which tends to be of this sort that's
mixed up about a good and bad and thinks
that's a obtaining security at the
expense of other people is a good or
that you know getting some sort of
embarrassment that we might feel and
pushing it off on something else is a
good thing for us we are probably going
to run through a lot of problems and
we're going to also set up situations
where other people who otherwise could
love us who could be friends with us are
going to say I hate that guy he is
terrible so what is the upshot of this
what is the other possibility
Epictetus gives us some interesting
advice he says if we want to see whether
people can really be friends we want to
look to their prior races to their
Faculty of choice don't look to other
forms of similarity whether they grew up
together in the same town whether they
share a common interest and are part of
a club together
whether they belong to the same nation
whether they're members of the same
corporate organization whether they're
both college professors whether they are
professor to students or students a
professor Epictetus thinks that people
will sell each other out in favor of
their own interest you know for external
goods if they haven't gotten their
faculty of choice
lined up right if they have then they
are actually the front
if you have two people like that they
are going to like each other because
they recognize the good in each other
does this mean that the Froning MOS is
unable to lying or feel affection
towards would be friends with anybody
who is not affirming most Epictetus
seems to be steering that way but it
doesn't necessarily have to go that way
because you know it's possible to
recognize the goodness even in people
who keep on screwing things up and say
well you know they are still my my child
they are still my father they are still
my friend I like things to be different
than that
Epictetus probably would not say that
you keep turning the other cheek you
know / verbally forever though he would
probably counsel that that people who
are as we say toxic personalities you
need to get them out of your life don't
try to be friends with them the amount
of constancy and intensity of affection
is probably going to be a matter that is
measured in part by how well together
that person he has there they're prone
races they're Faculty of choice they're
governing principle in their their life
so very interesting discussion here
about what would really be required for
genuine lasting friendship which the
stoical see is a good thing it sounds
rather pessimistic but a patinas would
say that he's actually being very
realistic